JOSH ESTELLE: All right.
Good morning, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
So my name's Josh Estelle.
I'm a software engineer.
I work on Google Translate.
I've been working on that for
about seven years, and I lead
our frontend and mobile teams.
Today, we're going to talk to
you about Google Translate.
And this is my colleague, Rohit,
who's going to talk to
you about the API towards the
second half of the talk.
We're going to talk
about why machine
translation is important.
We're going to talk about how
Google Translate works, and
then we're going to talk
about the API.
So the first thing I always like
to express to people is
that translation is hard.
This is not an easy task.
Forget about computers.
Forget about machines.
Just translating is
hard, even for us.
Even for the most multilingual,
most talented
linguists, translation is
a time-consuming task.
It takes a lot of energy.
It takes a lot of domain
knowledge.
This is a tough task.
So I like to really get that
out there before we kind of
get into teaching machines
to do that tough task.
This is already a hard
task for humans.
But at Google, we like
hard problems.
And I'm really proud
that we're able
to tackle this problem.
But we're not the first.
About 60 years ago, people
were already trying to do
machine translation.
A lot of people argue that
translation was actually the
first non-numerical task that
people tried to apply
computers to, right?
Before that, it was all
numerical calculations.
And this was still in the early
days of computing, but
they were already starting
about doing translation.
And at Georgetown, with a joint
project with IBM, they
started a project to do
machine translation.
In 1954, they did a public
demonstration.
Their demonstration was on the
IBM 701, which was the first
commercially-available
mainframe.
This was a big, old, slow
computer, but they did
translation on it.
Their system was very simple.
It had 250 vocabulary words and
six rules of grammar, and
their demo only did
60 sentences
from Russian to English.
Simple system, but really
impressed the public.
This really got people
excited and engaged.
And they were like, wow, these
amazing computer things.
They can do translation.
And tons of excitement, national
media coverage, and
it really excited the research
going on at that time.
And they predicted that they
would solve translation within
three to five years.
Three to five years, we'll
have this thing done.
Anyone who works on translation
now or has used
machine translation probably
realizes we didn't quite get
there in three to five years.
But we're getting closer.
There's been a lot of good
research and a lot of things
that have happened, especially
in the past 10 to 15 years,
that are getting us
a long ways along.
The first big one is
computational power.
I don't have to tell this
audience what's the amazing
things that we can do with
computers these days, and
especially comparing
to that IBM 701.
That machine could do two
multiplications every second.
The phones in our pockets
can do billions of
computations a second.
And for Google Translate, we
use data centers full of
machines with amazing
computational power.
The second piece we have now
is data, tons of data.
We train our system off all the
content on the web, right?
Think of how big that is.
Think about how many documents
are out there.
We use all of it to build
the translation system.
And then the last bit is where
research has come.
This is academic research,
industry research.
We've benefited from all that,
and we write our papers back
to that community as well.
But it has led to statistical
machine translation, which is
a different approach to
translation than that
rules-based system
of 50 years ago.
Rules-based machine translation
uses grammar
rules, and you try to hard
code those rules into a
computer and then run some
code that follows them.
Statistical machine translation
uses statistics
and probability to learn
language and learn how to
translations work from
lots of examples.
And I'll tell you more
about that later.
So let's get to Google
Translate.
So Google's mission, I hope
many of you know, is to
organize the world's information
and make it
universally accessible
and useful.
That piece of being universally
accessible, we see
machine translation as an,
essential part of that.
Without machine translation,
there's tons of content out in
the world that you're never
going to be able to
understand.
Now we're mostly English
speaking here, right, so we
maybe don't see this
as big a problem.
But we think about our
colleagues in China and Tokyo
and other places that have less
internet penetration, and
most of the internet is
not accessible to
them in their language.
So we think that machine
translation can
really enable that.
So let's get into a little
history of Google Translate.
All the way back in 2001, we had
our first system launch.
This was a third-party system
that we licensed, but this was
just three years after
Google was founded.
Larry and Sergey saw that need
for machine translation.
We had five languages initially
and then a couple
years later added a few more,
but all still licensed
third-party technology.
This technology was
state-of-the-art at the time,
but it was still that
rules-based machine
translation--
not all that different
from the Georgetown
experiment 60 years ago.
It improved, had definitely
gotten better, but still
wasn't that great.
So then in 2003, we started
taking a Google approach to
machine translation, to using
lots of data and lots of
computational power.
Think about how web search
works, right?
We use all that content on the
web, all the links between
pages, and from that we try to
find good search results.
We wanted to try the same
thing for translation--
use all those documents out on
the web, all those sentences,
all those translations, and
see if we could learn from
that data and come up with
good translations.
We weren't sure this
would work.
But then two years later, we
participated in the NIST
Machine Translation
evaluation.
NIST is the National Institute
for Standards and Technology.
And we were pleasantly surprised
that our system
really worked.
We outperformed all the other
competitors evaluated at that
evaluation, and we were really
proud of our system.
It proved our data-driven
approach could work and
established us as a leader
in the field.
Although at that time, our
research system, we only
translated 1,000 sentences for
that competition, and it took
us 40 hours to translate them.
You can imagine just a single
web page might have 1,000
sentences, and we translate
many of those now.
So this was way too slow.
We needed to make this fast.
So that was the next thing we
worked towards, and it took us
a couple more years before
we launched in 2006.
The first languages that we
launched were Chinese and
Arabic, and then a little later
that year, Russian.
So we kept going from there.
Here's a little slide of
all of our languages.
2007, we launched nine more,
and we replaced that
third-party system.
So now it was completely
our own technology.
2008, another 21 languages.
And the big deal that year was
before 2008, we couldn't
translate to any other language
besides English, right?
So Arabic to English, Chinese to
English, French to English.
In 2008, now you could translate
between any of our
languages, right?
So you could go Vietnamese to
Greek and then to Serbian to
Slovak, and go between any of
the languages we support.
We kept going from there,
launching lots more languages.
In 2011, we launched the
commercial API that we're
going to talk about later.
And now in 2013, my slide says
66 languages, and that's
what's listed there.
But I crossed it out, because
the beauty of continuing to
launch new languages is
my slides get out
of date really fast.
So I added this new slide.
We're now up to 71 languages,
just as of a
week and a half ago.
And the last five languages we
just launched are Bosnian,
Cebuano, Hmong, Javanese,
and Marathi.
So you see that we're starting
to get into languages that
really have a much smaller
amount of speakers out in the
world and much less data, which
is a big challenge for
us to get enough data to
build these systems.
So that's a little
of the history.
Let me get a little deeper
into how things work.
So people and machines, we
learn to translate very
differently than each
other, right?
So when humans learn to
translate or learn another
language, we learn
some vocabulary.
We start learning those
grammar rules.
We learn the exceptions to the
rules, the exceptions to the
exceptions, and the exception
to the exceptions to the
exceptions, and so on.
Anyone who's learned another
language knows what I mean.
With statistical machine
translation, that's not how
computers learn.
They just see lots and
lots of examples.
It's like just trying to read
hundreds of thousands of books
in two languages and just coming
out at the end and
knowing that language.
So instead of describing exactly
how that works, I'm
going to try to teach
you how to learn the
way a computer does.
So I'm going to start
with this example.
This is a Chinese menu, right?
We've got some soups, and this
menu has both the English menu
item and then the Chinese
for the same menu item.
This is a single parallel
example of text.
And if you look at the one
highlighted there, you can see
"egg drop" only appears in the
English text in three of the
items, and then we can find that
Chinese character that
only appears in those
same three items.
Now, I don't know for sure that
Chinese character means
"egg drop," but I think
it does, right?
It seems a good correspondence.
It probably does.
What about "chicken"?
So can you guys figure out
which character means
"chicken?" Raise your hand
once you figure it out.
OK, OK.
Good.
Yeah, so you don't know Chinese,
but now you know the
Chinese character for
"chicken," right?
So there it is for you,
for those of you who
are a little slower.
This also works for
phrases, right?
So "corn cream" aligns to these
two Chinese characters.
And my first example, right,
was "egg drop," two English
words to a single Chinese
character.
And then what about "soup"?
Can you find the Chinese
character for "soup"?
Yeah, so that one's a little
bit interesting.
So there's "soup."
But you'll notice in menu item
60, on the English side we say
"Cantonese wonton soup," but on
the Chinese side, we don't
see that character for "soup."
And then on 65, on the English
side, "egg drop wonton mix," but
then on the Chinese side,
we do have the character
for "soup."
So this shows that even in
situations where the
translations aren't precisely,
exactly the same word-for-word
kinds of things that we can
still learn that that
character means "soup," even
though it doesn't always work.
That's how a statistical
system works, right?
We learn all these probabilities
of translations
and that sort of thing.
So that was one document.
We need a lot more than
one document, right?
We need billions and billions
and billions of documents.
And the kind of documents we use
are less so like a Chinese
menu where both texts are
there, and they're more
parallel documents.
So we find a web page that the
original version might be in
English, but then they've
localized into 10 more
languages, and we would find all
those parallel documents.
Other good examples of parallel
documents are the
United Nations.
They publish all of their
documents in their six
official languages.
The European Parliament
publishes all of their
documents in 21 languages.
And that's all really
good data for us.
The UN data and the European
Parliament data, it's very
high-quality data, but it's
actually a very tiny amount.
It's like a little drop
in the bucket of the
amount of data we need.
The majority of our data, like
I was saying earlier, comes
from the web, right?
Tons of data on the web.
The problem with the web is
that data is noisy, right?
It is a mess.
Anyone who's done anything on
the web with processing web
data is like, this
stuff is crazy.
You find all sorts of messy
junk on the web.
But our system is able to learn,
and sort of in the same
way, that soup thing, right?
Imperfect things, right, we can
still learn from that data
and learn good translations.
So here's a diagram of how
our system works, a
simple version of it.
We've been talking mostly about
the translations in
parallel corpora.
The other part is modelling
and the model structure of
language that we use.
So this kind of describes
that.
So here's a German sentence
translated to English.
And we use a phrase-based
translation model.
And the way we model this is by
assigning probabilities to
certain aspects of
language, right?
The first one is segmentation.
We need to figure out how to
break that sentence up.
For German, at least we know
how to break up words.
Other languages, like
Lao, don't have
spaces between words.
So that becomes an even harder
problem, because you have to
find the space where the
word boundaries are.
At least German, we have the
word boundaries, but we still
find phrase boundaries, right?
We decide that "nach Kanada" is
a phrase, and we don't look
at just "nach" and
just "Kanada."
The second piece
is translation.
That's the sort of obvious one,
that a phrase translates
to another phrase, right?
So "nach Kanada" that translates
to "in Canada." .
So we have probabilities
for particular phrase
translations.
And then distortions, like
reordering, right?
So you can see how some of these
phrases flip around.
What our system does is we model
language in that way,
based on these probabilities.
This formula gives us the
probability of this English
sentence given the
German sentence.
And from data, we learn those
probabilities for lots of
phrases and possible ways of
doing this translation.
Then when you give us some new
text, we do a search process
through all the possible phrases
we've seen, all the
different things, to
produce the most
probable translated text.
Make sense?
Cool.
OK.
So where are we today with
Google Translate?
Google Translate,
translate.google.com, is our
main property.
We also have great mobile
apps on Android and iOS.
And Chrome is a really
interesting case.
A lot of you have probably
seen this.
When you land on a Chinese
page, it'll pop a little
banner down and say, hey,
this is Chinese.
Do you want to translate it?
And you're like, sure.
And then a second later--
less than a second later--
you've got a translated
web page.
We're seeing this really change
how people use the web,
because you're no longer running
into that language
barrier of like, oh, I wanted
to read about this temple in
China, but all I can find is
English guidebook things.
But really, I want to read what
the locals think about
this thing.
You can find some document
written in
Chinese and read it.
I think that's a really
incredible thing we can do
with Chrome.
We've got some really
cool numbers too.
So we've got over 200 million
users of Google Translate.
This is across our mobile apps
and our desktop apps.
92% of those users come
from outside the
United States, right?
So that's a big user base, and
not even big here in the
United States.
We're doing a billion
translations a day, and that's
the equivalent of the amount
of text you'd find in a
million books.
Every day, we're translating
that amount of text, and
that's more text than all of
the world's professional
translators translate
in an entire year.
So every day, we're translating
a massive amount
of content.
Cool.
So now I'm going to jump
into some demos.
And live demos always fail,
so we'll see how they go.
So I'm going to start with,
here's our desktop UI.
Hopefully, a lot of you are
familiar with that.
And I can type in to transition
"Google I/O 2013 is
the best." And then here,
you can see the Chinese
translation.
We can hover over these
phrases and
see how they align.
You can make edits.
You can click on this.
And the numerical date is fine,
but I'm going to change
it to the Chinese characters
here, because that helps me
learn the pronunciation
of those characters.
And then a newer feature we
launched just about a month
ago, it's called Phrasebooks.
This lets you save
translations that
are useful to you.
You can see that I'm vegetarian,
and so when I'm
traveling, I try to make sure I
have some phrases with me of
how to tell people in different
languages that I
don't eat meat.
So I've been saving
a bunch of those.
I'll save this one I just put
in here, which gives me the
chance to show you something
we launched in mobile just
last week, I think.
Let's see if can
switch to my--
oh, that's my son.
All right, I'm going to
switch away, so you
don't see my password.
OK, we're back.
So here's our translate app on
Android, and I've already
switched to the Phrasebook
view.
You can see those
same phrases.
And I can sync, and hopefully
we'll see-- yup, there's that
new phrase that I just put
in on the desktop.
In the Phrasebook, you can open
that up, and then we can
listen to that.
So I want to say this to my
friend I just met at I/O that
speaks Chinese.
[COMPUTER SPEAKING CHINESE]
JOSH ESTELLE: Pretty good?
How's my Chinese?
We got any Chinese speakers?
Pretty good?
Yeah, all right.
Cool.
You can also use this supersize
mode, right?
So if I need to reach someone
way in the back of the room,
they can read that.
Or this is great for showing a
cab driver where you need to
go, that sort of thing.
You don't have to hand
them your phone.
You're just kind of like,
look at this.
So that's that.
Some of the other things I'm
really excited about in our
mobile app is some of the
ways we're dealing
with inputting text.
So when you're traveling, it's
not always so easy to get text
into your app.
The first one is handwriting
input.
Us Americans, right, we're used
to keyboards like this.
But there's a lot of people in
the developing world that are
coming to mobile phones as their
first computing device,
and they're maybe not used to
ASCII keyboards, right?
They might be used to just
drawing Chinese characters.
That's how they've
always written.
So this handwriting is really
great for that.
I don't know that much Chinese,
but I know one.
I didn't quite get it right.
I know one kind of interesting
character.
Did I get it?
Come on.
Ah, shoot.
I'm going to try it
one more tine.
I assure you, this is not
our system's fault.
This is my terrible
Chinese fault.
Can I get "fire"?
Yeah, fire.
ROHIT KHARE: Fire.
JOSH ESTELLE: Wait, no.
There's not a fire.
Don't worry.
Cool, so that's handwriting.
The next one is camera input.
So let's imagine we're
in a zoo in Tokyo.
Rohit's going to help me out.
He's going to be my zoo sign.
What does this say?
I have no idea.
Well, I'm in Tokyo, so I better
change this to Japanese.
I'll just take a picture
of that, get
that lined up in there.
And so this will recognize the
text, and then I can just
swipe my finger over the text
I want to understand.
And now, oh, there we go.
The amphibious reptile house
must be over there somewhere.
Watch out for amphibians
if you're sitting in
that side of the room.
Cool.
And then also if you, need to
talk to someone, we have
conversation mode, which
will handle your voice.
Since we're in conversation
mode, I can just be like,
"Hey, do you know where the
amphibious reptile house is?"
[COMPUTER SPEAKING JAPANESE]
JOSH ESTELLE: All right.
Of course, I just read the sign,
so I'm not sure why I
needed to ask that.
I was just double checking.
So that's conversation mode.
And then the last thing, I'm
really excited about-- we
launched pretty recently--
is what if you're at a
conference and the wireless is
really terrible, and you just
can't seem to get the
translations you need?
I'm going to simulate that by
going into airplane mode.
Now I'm just going
to type here.
"Hello." Oh, and I still
have a translation.
"How are you?" So this
translation is all happening
offline, on my device, no
network connection.
Pretty cool, huh?
So this is a great when
you're traveling.
You've got expensive data.
You've got maybe no data at
all, but you can still do
translation.
Now this does require you to
download some language packs.
So each language is about
100 megabytes of data.
But once you have it, you can do
offline translations, which
we're really excited about.
Cool.
So let me just talk
a little bit more
about where we're going.
What's next for Google
Translate?
More languages.
We're up to 71.
That's a great number, but
there are thousands of
languages in the world, and we
want to keep adding more.
So I'm sure someone after this
talk is going to come ask me,
what about my language?
We get that all the time, and I
promise we're working on it.
It always becomes a matter of if
we can get enough data for
a particular language.
So usually the best thing
people can do is get
translated content out on the
web where it can be crawled.
And we'll find it, and we'll
learn from it, and it'll help
our system.
We want better quality,
of course.
We're really proud
of our quality.
We think our translations
are really usable.
They can help you understand
a document.
They can help you communicate.
They're not perfect though.
You don't necessarily want to
localize your website just
straight up and trust the
machine translation without
anyone reviewing it, right?
You want to be careful.
But we want to get there.
We want our translations to
get better and better.
We also want translation
to be ubiquitous.
No matter where you are, you
should have access to a
translation.
So if you're browsing a website
in Chrome, boom, you
get it translated.
You run into a sign, you pull
out your phone, you get it
translated.
There are still places that
are hard for people to get
translations.
We want to make sure any time
you encounter text that you
can get it.
And we want real-time
communication.
So we want you to be able to
translate things instantly,
quickly, right when
you need it.
We want those conversations to
happen, spoken, real-time
conversations in other
languages too.
So with that, I'll turn it over
to Rohit, and he's going
to tell you more
about the API.
ROHIT KHARE: Yeah.
Thank you, Josh.
Glad for the introduction to
the science behind Google
Translate, and I think I want
to talk to you about what we
do with it and what you
can do with it.
What's important to realize that
we think translation's
important in context.
So if I receive a Gmail that's
happens to be in Japanese,
notice that we have that link
right there to convert that
back to English.
Now, we use this in our consumer
applications, like
Docs and Spreadsheets.
We use it in our internal
applications, like approving
advertising, and understanding
how Search queries should be
indexed and shared
across languages.
But we use our own
dog food here.
We use and API, and we make them
over with third parties.
So this is a screenshot from a
partner called The Backplane.
They are a social site that
started out with Lady Gaga's
management company and are now
working with other brands like
Nike and Coke and so on.
And they create communities
for fans.
And unlike, say, a friendship
community of people you met at
college, who will probably all
speak the same language, the
superfans around the world
really are passionate and love
to connect, but they
don't always
speak the same language.
So here in this chat, we can
see that an English speaker
and an Italian speaker
are able to go
fluidly back and forth.
And they're using the same
API technology as
we do here at Google.
So the important thing I want to
say up front is that a lot
of the translate technology we
just saw is very advanced, and
there's some very amazing things
you can do by combining
speech and handwriting and
image recognition.
But I want to say that the core
technology is very much
open for business.
It's part of the Google Cloud
Platform, and you've heard a
lot about that this week at
Google I/O. We have basic
services in compute, like App
Engine and Compute Engine,
storage services, but also a
great way to take advantage of
the best of that Google has to
offer, from apps to Maps to
APIs for data processing and
advertising analytics, and
including Translate.
Translate's been around
since late 2011.
It's one of our larger and more
successful businesses
within the cloud.
Over 3 million developers use
the Cloud Platform projects,
and 300,000 folks come
and work on the
platform every month.
And we'd like keep growing that,
and this is a key part
of that strategy.
And it's $20 per million
characters translated.
And it's not always easy to get
your head around that, but
$1 for localization can often
get just a word or two.
But in machine translation, that
can be over 100 pages of
English content.
It's often the case people say,
well, is $20 per million
characters expensive or not?
And it's actually quite
reasonable.
It's best to get out there and
start experimenting, and you
can scale up.
Until you even have
Wikipedia-style content, you
will still not be taking that
much that goes out of your
data quota limits.
So how do you call it?
Real briefly mechanics.
It's really quite simple.
As said, there's Core
2 core services.
In this case, we're doing a
GET request with your API
console key.
Here's "hello world." I want
the target in German.
We're automatically detecting
the source language and giving
you the output, "hallo welt,"
and telling you that we
thought it was English source.
We also do great things with
automatic HTML parsing.
We're often doing an input
that's coming in from the web.
And in this case, this is that
phrase about going to the
conference.
And the conference, you'll here
notice is capital K in
German, and the word "fly" is
in bold, in bold markup.
And here's the output where
"fly" is in bold, but notice
it's much earlier
in the sentence.
The C in conference has
been lowercased.
So it's always great for
realizing that you can use
HTML markup, and the
markup will float
with the correct phrase.
So this again makes it a little
easier to integrate in
your websites.
And it's available also in
products like Google Apps
Script, if you're working for
lightweight prototyping in our
Spreadsheets or Docs.
Here's the same phrase
in Spanish.
So the important thing you need
to realize is that we're
taking the two most important
core things about our
Statistical Machine Translation
engine, which is
language detection, which is
that you know what your
input's coming in as, and
language translation between
our supported languages.
Sometimes we do a release.
Our most recent languages
will be in Alpha.
We're working on our data.
Some of them are not yet
supported in the API, but by
and large, as they graduate,
they are always available to
you through the API.
Now, of course, we have a lot
of products where we make it
free to our consumers.
For commercial use, for you as
third-party developers, we
definitely want to
encourage that.
But we have kind of two
key rules of the road.
One is attribution.
It's really important that
humans know that this is
machine-translated output
in case there
are errors or omissions.
It's really important to us that
humans know that it's our
machine-translation output,
and if you want to use the
Google logo, there are some
additional rules and
suggestions about
how to do that.
But it's also important that
machines know that it's
machine-translation output.
As he mentioned, the way machine
translation works is
by building upon all the work
in the parallel corpora, the
parallel text that are out
there that humans create.
And the last thing we want to
see is taking content from our
API and republishing it back on
the web in a way that makes
other research groups and
developers' input less reliable.
So with that, the rules of the
road on how it works and how
to call it, I want to talk about
when it gets used, and
talk about two broad cases I
looked at when we saw our
traces of who was using
our API and for what.
Now, some developers are
offline, are some developers
are on the web.
So in looking at our logs, I
found a couple of clusters of
people who I thought
were offline.
And one huge area of growth is
mobile applications, and
you're delivering the experience
on Android or iOS
or BlackBerry.
You could simply make an
internet call, a REST call,
and display that online on
the tablet, on the phone.
We've see business process
applications.
For example, at Google we use
all of our bug reports that
come in from the field.
We have clustering algorithms
and train people who look at
the field reports, but we have
to bring them back into a
common language, say
English, to do so.
So these are back office
processes.
There are media monitoring
applications, where you want
to know how your brand or
company is being perceived
around the world.
And so rather than just
translate the name of your
products and see how many times
it gets mentioned in the
media, why not bring all that
media in, translate those
entire articles, and be able to
look at the sentiment and
look at the themes and the
content around the world.
And another subclass was around
hybrid translation companies.
So you take machine-translation
output,
and you might have expertise in
medical or real estate or
in a certain country,
and you have a staff
that makes that better.
So there are companies that
have used our API to help
bootstrap the translation
process.
But most visibly, you've
probably seen Google Translate
on the web.
And an obvious place
is e-commerce.
If you can put it in
a box and FedEx it,
you can be an exporter.
But you can't export
much unless your
customers can find you.
And so we want to do our best
to make sure that you can
create your product listings,
your product reviews, get them
indexed, get them visible, and
attract new customers.
But I was also surprised to find
out the largest customer
within e-commerce turned out to
be stuff you can't put in a
box and export.
It was hotels and hostels
and vacation rentals.
And it wasn't the product
descriptions, it was the reviews.
It's what people said when
they came from abroad,
reviewed a place, and allowed
other travelers who maybe also
didn't speak that language to
know what they thought of it.
And this theme was really
enlightening to me.
And we'll come back to some of
the lessons I learned from
that later.
But that's a case where, even
if you think you're a local
merchant running B&B in
Monterrey, you should probably
still consider translation.
I can have an impact
on your business.
Multimedia content.
There's a lot of content on the
web today that's video,
that's images, that's
photographs and newswire
photos or product imagery that's
perfectly usable in
multiple languages.
You don't need to
read to use it.
But you can't find it unless
that metadata, caption,
program guide, and so
on is available to
people in those languages.
Language learning.
This was a smaller sector, but
it was interesting that even
machine translation, which can
be approximate at times, can
be very useful in an interactive
setting where you
are in a game or you're in
a community classroom or
somewhere where a TA
can help you out.
So places where you have an
interactive application can be
also a really good
fit for our API.
And finally, social
communities.
And it was important to think
that it wasn't just
communication applications,
like SMSes or places where
people are communicating across
borders, but places
where you can find shared
passions and communities--
forum sites, rare diseases,
passionate collectors of
various items.
These are cases where your
community might be better
served by pulling it all in one
place than having separate
language communities and
separate language sites.
So from these bunch of examples
of companies that are
using it on the web,
let's talk about a
couple of key themes.
One is think about machine
translation when you need to
get the gist of things.
Human translation is great, but
the sheer cost and scale
says that we're not going to
be able to organize the
world's information unless we
use machine translation.
But it's important to know its
strengths and weaknesses.
And the thing was, when you're
looking at reviews, like a
hotel review, I didn't need
to worry about whether the
grammar was perfect in the
way that you expect of a
well-written YouTube comment.
Comments and reviews are really
great content, even if
you can only get the
sense of it.
You have to think about reach,
which is, are you building a
site or an app where your
audience is going to be
reaching you in multiple
languages and multiple
communities?
And that's often earlier
than you think.
You might assume that your
audience is only shipping to
one country in Europe, say in
France, but that doesn't mean
that you only need to
communicate in French.
You also have French
consumers who
speak all the EU languages.
And bulk.
Think about machine translation
when there are
applications that no one ever
thought of doing with human
translation because it
was so obviously
prohibitive to do so in cost.
But if you can look at media
monitoring or look at your old
customer reports or look at a
large amount of text, and work
with all of your reviews rather
than just a few that
seem to be for the top hotels.
And finally, look for cases
where the user is in control.
Machine translation is great if
the user has initiated or
requested the translation
process, or is aware that I'm
flipping between the original
Turkish and the English.
Or if the user is the one who's
creating the content in
the first place, and they have
the chance or the opportunity
to know that, by telling us
that you're OK with this
language, that your review will
now be read by people
visiting this pizza place
from all over the world.
So with this, I'd like to bring
it back together and say
these are part of the whole
suite of tools at Google and
at other places in the world
to help you go global with
your site or your app.
There are new markets.
There are no more monolingual
markets.
Even in the United States,
Hispanic consumers control
over a trillion dollars
in household spending.
There is a reason for growth,
because you have to be able to
take in input and feedback
that you're getting and
understand what your customers
are telling you and how you
can expand.
There are opportunities to
make sure that you are in
compliance.
There are a variety of
rules and cultural
norms around the world.
And even if you're not yet
operating in that language, at
least knowing what your users
are saying in those languages,
so you can review that and
be sure that that's in
compliance.
And to help create
connections.
Because I think the next wave
of global growth isn't by
franchising your business and
saying, I'm going to create a
.ru site and a .jp site.
But try and see if you can
create a network effect and
connect your user base around
the world in one product.
So that's where we'd like to
wrap up, is that our mission
is to help organize the world's
information and make
it universally accessible
and useful.
We found this to be an
incredibly powerful tool
across a range of
Google products
and business processes.
We've taken the best of that and
the core of that product
knowledge and made it
available to you.
And I'd like to hear now if
you have questions and
resources about how we can help
other folks do the same.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ROHIT KHARE: Some of
our related links.
JOSH ESTELLE: So if there's
questions, there's two
microphones if people
want to stand up.
We've got about five minutes
for questions.
ROHIT KHARE: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi I'm Luc, and I just
wanted to ask about the
offline translation.
Would you make this available
for business
developers and so on?
JOSH ESTELLE: So we don't
have plans to now.
But this is good feedback,
right?
We're always looking for ways
of what the next thing we
might add to the API or how
we can expand that.
We're really excited about
offline now, and we can
understand that developers
would be too.
So it's something we
can look into.
ROHIT KHARE: Yeah, I'd love to
hear more about your use case.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Do you provide a confidence
score in the API?
So I could know when the
confidence is little, I would
call in a human translator, and
if it's high, I'm good to
go and can ship it out?
JOSH ESTELLE: Yeah.
So right now we don't.
Providing confidence for
machine translation is
actually a really, really
hard problem.
You can imagine if you would
solve the problem of
confidence, you would just
generate a bunch of
translations and just pick the
one that had the highest
confidence.
So in some ways, generating
confidence is as hard as doing
translation is.
So internally, we've tried some
things around confidence,
that sort of thing.
None that we're happy with
enough that we've even exposed
in our UI in anyway, or think
you would actually benefit
from in the API.
It's an understandable
thing to want.
We want it too, but it's
really hard to do.
So right now, we don't have
a way to do that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOSH ESTELLE: Yeah.
OK.
Any other questions?
ROHIT KHARE: Well, we'll be
around for a few minutes.
We'll be glad to talk about
individual scenarios.
Thanks very much.
JOSH ESTELLE: And we
have stickers if
anyone wants stickers.
ROHIT KHARE: Yes, we have lots
of Translate stickers.
Thank you very much.
JOSH ESTELLE: Thanks.